the towns here on the front lines in
eastern ukraine sit dangerously close to
the areas controlled by the
russian-backed separatists
this is marinka where life is divided in
two
there was a time before the war in 2014
when there was calm
now it's a place literally on the edge
the shells came out of nowhere
violations of the ceasefire
this video posted to social media claims
to show the terrifying moment as they
crashed onto the streets
this woman was hit by shrapnel her hand
badly injured
other areas along the dividing line also
experienced barrages of artillery before
they went quiet again
walking around these border towns it's a
very strange experience on the one hand
everything's normal there's cars
on the streets there's people around
there's houses there's shops open
but on the other hand
just about 500 meters away you have the
front lines and just beyond that the
russian-backed separatists
and what it means
is that the war is never far away
the principal of the local school fears
this could be the start of another
sustained round of fighting or worse
she shows me to the basements where
she'd led the children when the shelling
started
it's basic but safe
with sleeping bags water and medical
supplies
no one here knows where this conflict is
going for them this is another episode
in a war which has changed their lives
and town they hope peace will come one
day but are not expecting any miracles
alex rossi sky news marine corps